l'hérault et après donc des signes
d'apaisement hier dans ce dossier
comment expliquer ce retour des tensions
aujourd'hui entre l'occident et les
russes comment rétablir ou même établir
tout simplement la confiance durement
gagné mais qui semble bien fragile c'est
l'heure de notre décryptage
[Musique]
est avec nous pour en parler sur ce pet
au clos de manche maison expert en
relations internationales bonsoir clos
blanchemaison merci d'être avec nous
philippe béchade économistes rédacteur
en chef de la bourse aux au quotidien
merci d'être avec nous également et pour
nous aux accompagné durant une dizaine
de minutes thierry mariani député
européen est reine bonsoir thierry
mariani t merci d'être là hier à la même
heure on parlait donc plutôt
d'apaisement ce soir on a l'impression
d'un retour à la case départ et même
d'une certaine escalade quand on entend
l'otan qui renforce ses troupes
notamment aussi les etats unis ces
parachutistes ans en pologne les
occidentaux qui disent douter vraiment
de ce retrait des forces russes le
kremlin deal inverse pourquoi est-ce
aussi difficile d'établir ou de rétablir
on ne sait pas si elle a un jour existé
la confiance claude blanche maison en
effet hier est d'ailleurs avant-hier
soir aussi la communication russe avait
soufflé dans le sens d'une désescalade
on avait d'ailleurs mobilisés à la
télévision russe le ministre de la
défense monsieur shungu qui avait
expliqué que les manoeuvres qui avaient
lieu autour de l'ukraine et bien
certaines se termine et d'autres se
terminait dans les jours prochains et
qu'au fur et à mesure les troupes qui
participait rejoindre l or leur lieu
garnison d'origine et monsieur lavrov
dans le maine la même émission disait à
monsieur poutine qui était à l'autre
bout de la salle du conseil des
ministres est bien en effet il y a
encore beaucoup d espace pour la
négociation et donc nous devons nous
devons négocier donc il y avait un
sentiment d'apaisement bien sûr certains
doutent du de de la delà de la réalité
du retrait des troupes mais c'est pas le
vrai problème je pense que les troupes
se retirent en effet au fur et à mesure
de la fin des manoeuvres mais le vrai
sujet c'est que les difficultés
commencent maintenant aujourd'hui parce
qu'on se rend compte que une fois là des
escales à la mort c est bien le vrai
sujet c'est qu'est ce qu'on fait des
demandes russe or les demandes russe
c'est les demandes très précis par écrit
de garanties de sécurité pour la russie
et c'est extraordinairement difficile
alors bien sûr les américains ont
répondu partiellement en disant on est
prêt à négocier des accords bilatéraux
sur les forces nucléaires intermédiaire
puisque le traité a été déchirée par
monsieur choï on est prêt à négocier
aussi
d'aider des mesures de nature à
restaurer la confiance notamment la
transparence des manoeuvres les changes
d'observateurs mais monsieur poutine
répond oui d'accord ça c'est très bien
mais c'est pas le sujet principal le
sujet principal c'est que je veux
obtenir des garanties de sécurité pour
la russie est effectivement l'abcès de
fixation c'est l'ukraine par conséquent
rien n'est résolu et en effet comme en
plus il ya la rumeur que le la douma
demanderait la reconnaissance des débuts
de l'indépendance du dombass ça voudrait
dire qu'on déchire est tout simplement
les accords de minsk thierry mariani est
effectivement cette demande auprès de la
l'huma d'oumar on imagine que ça
exacerbe les détentions important le
kremlin pour le moment n'a pas du tout
répondu favorablement en ce sens n'est
ce pas
écoutez je suis à strasbourg où elle
nous avions aujourd'hui à un débat j'ai
envie de dire comme à chaque session
parce qu'à chaque session à strasbourg
on a droit au débat sur les méchants
russes qui menace l'europe on avait un
débat sur la situation en ukraine et
bien sûr à la frontière avec la russie
et paradoxalement personne à parler de
ce vote à la douma qui est quand même à
mon avis à prendre en compte qu'est ce
que c'est c'est comme l'a dit monsieur
l'ambassadeur l'écrasante majorité des
députés de la douma qui ont fait une
sorte d' adresse ou de voeux au
président un poutine pour demander la
reconnaissance des deux républiques
lougansk et de lietz comme état
indépendant puisque en réalité le statut
d'autonomie promis par que le traité à
part les accords de minsk il ya sept ans
n'a toujours pas été établies mais après
si vous me permettez on est toujours au
parlement européen dans une situation
surréaliste parce que vous le savez pas
mais la guerre a déjà commencé parce que
quand je lis la délibération conviennent
de voter il faut les français comme
d'ailleurs les contribuables européens
savent qu'aujourd'hui on a encore donné
un milliard de à l'ukraine 1 milliard
d'euros à la crème je cite pour l'été à
faire face à la rapide croissance de ses
besoins en raison du conflit
c'est un peu bizarre parce que
visiblement il ya toujours pas de guerre
mais l'europe s'est précipité pour
donner un milliard de il ya quelque
chose que les contribuables européens
doivent savoir c'est ce que nous coûte
la faillite de l'état européen je vais
vous citer des chiffres qui sont
extraits du rapport de la cour des
comptes européenne
c'est par l'achat today c'est pas
thierry mariani c'est la cour des
comptes européenne elle dit dans son
rapport de septembre que jusqu'à présent
là on a donné depuis 2014 à l'union à la
à l'ukraine 17 milliards 17 milliards
donc vous rajoutez un milliard vidéo
aujourd'hui ça veut dire que les
contribuables français entre 9 millions
de prêts
par 9 millions de dont
8 millions de prêts qui ne seront jamais
remboursés et désormais 1 milliard
aujourd'hui c'est donc plus de 17 plus 1
18 milliard qu'on a donné à l'ukraine
pour je cite le rapport de la cour des
comptes et je préfère vous lire la
phrase le rapport commence par l'ukraine
est miné par la corruption notamment par
la grande corruption depuis de
nombreuses années que les fonds
européens ont contribué à enrichir voilà
quand même s'est heureusement pas une
situation guerrière mais il faut pas
oublier que derrière cette situation
c'est aussi je pèse mes mots une aubaine
pour l'ukraine de demander encore plus
d'argent aux contribuables européens
justement sur ce plateau philippe
béchade à cette somme faramineuse
s'ajoute le milliard promis aussi par
les états unis
je crois que c'était hier où il ya 48
heures à l'ukraine
ça vous inspire quoi parce que c'est
vrai qu'on n'en parle assez peu un de
ces coups de pouce entre guillemets je
sais pas comment les appeler ses
subventions à l'ukraine on les
interprète comment alors essayé de
restituer les choses
l'ukraine c'est un pib j'avais le
compteur
il était à 168 milliards le pib
d'ukraine c160 lumière donc 17 milliards
donnés par l'europe c'est en quelque
sorte 10% du pib de l'ukraine
le milliard de ou le milliard 4 ça
compense en fait la baisse de redevances
perçues par l'ukraine sur le transit du
gaz russe vers la pologne vers
l'autriche notamment
le débit ou plutôt la quantité de gaz
qui a transité l'année dernière était en
baisse de
25% donc pour l'ukraine gros manque à
gagner alors j'aurai rappeler que
l'ukraine c'est un pays actuellement où
l'inflation est de 13,7 pour cent et les
salaires ne suivent pas du tout ça je
peux vous en acier je peux vous
l'assurer pour tous les fonctionnaires
les profs et cetera les moins les fins
de mois deviennent très très difficile
la situation aujourd'hui en ukraine elle
est explosive en interne pour des
raisons économiques et c'est vrai que
l'europe déverse si j'ose dire
des cautères sur une sur une jambe de
bois solidarité en fait thierry mariani
c'est
c'est un une règle au sein du parlement
européen il ya une forme de solidarité
quand quand l'un des membres sur quel
fondement c'est ce qu'on essaye de
savoir ici sur quels fondements
effectivement parce que la dette on
avait suivi en grèce obéit à des
procédures très strictes là on est dans
le cadre d'une procédure très strict
alors le fondement il est
essentiellement politique parce que vous
savez comme moi que l'ukraine n'est pas
membre de l'union européenne et donc en
réalité c'est une aide politique dans le
cadre du partenariat qu'on a avec
certains pays à nos frontières
frontières de l'union européenne mais
mais je répète moi ce qui me choque
c'est pas les montants c'est que l'union
européenne reconnaît la cour des comptes
de l'union européenne reconnaît que ces
fonds ne servent à rien c'est à dire
qu'en réalité ils sont dilapidés par la
corruption et je vous invite vos
auditeurs à regarder sur internet le
rapport de la cour des comptes il dit
clairement que on n'arrive pas à tracer
où vont ces faut donc non seulement
malheureusement les ukrainiens en sang
dans une situation économique difficile
les européens j'allais dire comme tribu
a essayé de les aider mais ces fonds
n'arrivent pas au destinataire un club
dans sa maison j'imagine vous avez eu
vent évidemment de ces sommes allouées
ce n'est pas un secret les états unis
encore une fois on communiqué il ya deux
jours c'est quelque chose qui peut vous
étonner à partir du moment effectivement
ou le cred mais n'est pas membre de
l'union européenne
oui c'est pas très étonnant parce qu au
parlement européen et enfin le ministre
mariani le sait mieux que moi évidemment
et des mouvements politiques qui
traversent le parlement et qui a
probablement une majorité qui veut faire
quelque chose qui veut se manifester
politiquement cela dit le pouvoir
budgétaire il est partagé il est partagé
entre le parlement et le conseil et au
bout du compte on n'a pas fini cette
discussion mais je partage l'avis
de monsieur mariani sur l'usagé qui
pourrait être fait de ces sommes si elle
devait être confirmée parce que en effet
l'ukraine n'est pas en état d'absorber
des sommes de ceux de ce montant pour
les diriger vers le développement
économique donc c'est un c'est un geste
politique alors pour revenir à ces
menaces d'invasion qui persistent à 1
dans la presse anglo saxonne il y avait
d'ailleurs cette date du 16 février un
qui a été précisé à plusieurs reprises
vous philippe béchade vous n'y avez
jamais cru pour quelles raisons
d'abord
voilà je restitue une nouvelle fois la
russie ses 170 milliards de pib et
l'ukraine c'est dix fois moins ça situe
déjà l'échelle et l'ukraine ses 45
milliard d'habitants la russie c'est 140
autrement dit on a à peu près
un tiers d'habitants pour un pib
inférieur de 10 par un facteur 10 donc
je dire que l'ukraine si on envahit ce
pays là c'est un véritable boulet
économique la russie n'est pas
l'allemagne de 1990 qui peut
[Musique]
réformer l'allemagne de l'est et en
faire une zone prospère en trois ou
quatre ans alors après il faut pas
perdre non plus de vue une chose c'est
que là on est dans un coup de billard à
trois bandes
où il ya effectivement le gaz qui
transite par l'ukraine et on sait que la
russie voudrait qu'il en transit le
moins possible et plus par nord stream
actuellement d'ailleurs une partie du
gaz qui passent par
là le bélarus donc aujourd'hui les
occidentaux qui voient très très bien le
jeu que joue la russie qui essaye en
fait de deals et avec surtout
l'allemagne les occidentaux eux essayent
de vendre leur gnl et il ya un pays qui
est tout à fait partie prenante la halle
danse et le canada bon c'est bien sûr
que les américains eux se sont autorisés
il ya déjà deux ans à exporter le gnl
qui remplacerait en fait le gaz russe
s'il n'arrivait pas ils n'arrivaient
plus par l'ukraine et s'ils n'arrivaient
pas par notre nord stream 2 mais les
canadiens sont également parties
prenantes puisqu'ils ont le projet
goldboro avec une usine de liquéfaction
en nouvelle écosse et une autre qui
pourrait se construire sur la côte ouest
et les canadiens ont également envoyé
des troupes 900 900 soldats je ne sais
plus ont été déployés en pologne ou en
roumanie mais en tout cas on voit bien
qu'il ya des occidentaux qui essayent de
sécuriser en fait de potentiel débouché
en cas de conflit voilà on va bientôt
libérés thierry mariani qui est qui qui
doit s'éclipser dernière question
justement là c'était la version
économiquement fin qui qui pèse aussi il
n'y a pas de que la politique de dents
vous vous y croyez à cette des escales à
thierry mariani
je crois d'abord que comme philippe
béchade que la russie n'a aucun intérêt
à l'affrontement et aujourd'hui on a une
sorte de montée en tension artificielle
qui en réalité est alimenté
essentiellement par les états unis et
les britanniques et je ne crois
absolument pas ce conflit voilà c'est je
pense que les russes sens rationnel et
ils savent qu'ils ont beaucoup à perdre
après regardez aujourd'hui un peu
l'intérêt de économique c'est une bonne
démarche j'ai vu par j'ai vu la démarche
d'un commissaire européen se rendant à
new york pour voir washington pardon
pour voir
la question d'un approvisionnement par
l'europe avec du gaz américain j'ai vu
dans ouest france que désormais le gaz
de schiste américain arrivé au à saint
nazaire
voilà je pense que il ya effectivement
une forte odeur comme très souvent
d'énergie derrière ces menaces merci
thierry mariani on vous libère on va
poursuivre quelques minutes encore ce
débat et on vous l'hiver merci d'avoir
été avec nous claude blanche maison ce
soir en tout cas les négociations se
poursuivant les tractations olaf scholz
qu'ils reparlent à joe biden qu'est ce
qu'on peut attendre de cet entretien
parce qu'ils nous a assez surpris
finalement le chancelier allemand on
disait qu'il était un petit peu perdu
sur ce dossier finalement il ya eu
quelques petites avancées lors de son
entrevue avec avesnières poutine enfin
il est d'abord eu la chance parce que le
jour où il est à moscou il y avait cette
éclaircie et cette impression de
désescalade alors effectivement il a
tenu un discours assez ferme mais en
même temps en disant comme tout le monde
d'ailleurs qu'il fallait ouvrir un grand
espace à la négociation est donc à la
diplomatie alors est ce que on ne le
sait pas il a été question north stream
ii ou pas je n'en suis pas sûr
d'ailleurs parce que il est clair que
s'il ya des opérations militaires il n'y
aura pas de nord stream 2 mais la
contrepartie c'est que joe biden a bien
dit que nord stream ii n'existerait plus
si les troupes russes pénétrait en
ukraine mais comme les troupes russes ne
vont pas pénétrer en ukraine il devrait
y avoir north stream 2 1 jour pas tout
de suite pas pour cet hiver pour l'hiver
prochain mais la question reste ouverte
et encore une fois je ne crois pas non
plus à l'intervention militaire sur le
sol ukrainien
les troupes qui sont massés aux
frontières ne seront pas retirés tout de
suite certaines d'entre elles y aura une
certaine d escalade mais elles
continueront à rester là pour faire
pression pour faire pression sur la
négociation politique est encore une
fois une négociation dans laquelle
vladimir poutine veut obtenir des
garanties de sécurité pour la russie et
ces négociations auront lieu pour
l'essentiel avec les états unis
d'amérique et pour partie avec les
européens dans un câble qui pourrait
être un cadre doit se renouveler infini
béchard le mode est fait pour vous nous
devions réagir à ce que disait de
blanche maison c'est vrai que ce gazoduc
est au centre effectivement de tous ces
enjeux et coincé ici ou là dans ce
fameux jeu de billard alors faut se
rappeler que le projet north stream ii
il a été validé et il a été en fait qu
opéré par angela merkel bon arrive un
nouveau gouvernement et notamment
ministre de l'écologie au namm bareback
pour ne pas la nommer qui elle s'est
vraiment prononcé contre donc ce que
angela merkel avait fait ben bernanke
est en train en quelque sorte de le
défaire sauf si monsieur choi c'est
quand même moi qui décide mais c'est moi
qui suis en pourparlers directs avec
vladimir poutine donc on verra ce qu'il
en ressortira mais figure je partage le
sentiment que nord stream 2 avant qu on
ouvre les robinets qui assez juste il ya
juste ça sert un il va falloir
effectivement que l'on poursuive les
tractations que les sociétés
d'exploitation se domicilient en
allemagne que l'allemagne ait le
sentiment pu vendre aux états unis comme
aux européens qu'elle a la haute main
sur le contrôle de nord stream et c'est
donc ça va pas évidemment se faire tout
de suite maintenant l'invasion de
l'ukraine je pense qu'effectivement les
intérêts économiques sont assez faibles
alors concertent l'ukraine c'est le
septième producteur d'acier au monde
mais je rappelle que le premier
producteur d'acier en ukraine c'est
quand même le groupe arcelormittal et
ils produisent plus de 10 millions de
tonnes d'acier je pense que jusqu'à
présent arcelor n'a rien dit et
je pense pas qu'ils se préparent à ce
que leurs usines soient bombardés dans
l'est dans les jours qui viennent en
tout cas si un groupe occidental qui à
perdre en ukraine c'est d'abord arcelor
merci en tout cas à tous les deux raison
philippe béchade d'avoir été avec